First of all, what is a proposal for you?
The thing is, at my point of view, you shouldn't go to the death column of how to say, you don't need to really sell it.
Selling is, hey, we can do this, this will save this amount of time.
How do you say, I got disrupted to make a proposal.
You should almost be as blunt as you can be there.
At my point of view, this is more from, hey, this is the...
This is a project, basically. This is the project, basically.
The automation of the... how do you say?
We need to automate the N8N.
We need to automate the N8N, and how do you say?
We need to start automating our workflows using N8N.
We know how to do that. There are some key ones that need to be set up.
But we also want to train the... how do you say?
The DevOps team, to use the same tooling, and maybe also the consultants.
Because this is a tooling that will be used by the company, why there are some moments.
But the thing is...
I think it's going to start in 121, but then it's probably going to be adopted by other parts of the company.
Yeah, currently we are, how do you say, needing this one in the development cycle.
But it's probably going to... how do you say?
N8N has been already selected as the automation tool.
This, for example, was the proposal that I made for, I think it was personally.
Which was just like... it's just a presentation, honestly.
But it gives them all the information that they might need.
I don't know if that is also like...
You can present it in this way, or there is no...
The thing is this... how do you say?
Or is it easier for them if it's just a tiny document that they just have to read?
How do you say? You can have a short form, you can have a short form from, hey, this is like an executive...
Something that you can read from one glance, this is what it is, this is what it calls.
How do you say? This is what it gives, this is what it calls, this is what it's going to empower.
Because it's not fixed, because we are empowered, we try to empower that.
And then you can add, how do you say? You could almost like in blocks, each one of them.
And then in detail you could have one where you have it more in detail, like the more information on it.
I think that glance, because this is too much destruction, how do you say?
I just more or less need to go ahead from yes, yes, yes, and then I can take you, yes, yes, yes.
That is more or less what is the need.
If we are how to say at this moment, just for you to know, at this moment even is doing this one already,
because he's needing the same workflows anyway himself.
Victor is going to now do this part manually still, because he doesn't know the workflows yet.
So we are getting experience and then Victor can validate the quality from what Victor,
what even is making, because the next one will already go automatically.
But for the proposal, that is already something about the project, proposal-wise?
Yeah, the proposal-wise is from hey, this automated flow will take automatically projects and that is from OK.
Now for example, my time estimate was you will have a demo in two weeks, you will probably have the final product in four weeks.
No, no.
It has to be like that.
No, the thing is, even, how you say even is already has to make this one,
this needs to be tested the coming week and whatsoever rolled out next week.
Months, we don't think months anymore, weeks is what you should be taking off.
And you have that speed, it's getting there.
Sure.
I mean, my time estimate was four weeks.
Yeah, no, this thing, how do you say, that doesn't mean, no, no, this, again, even already set this up,
we just need to try it out, does it work?
How do you know even already set it up?
Because I talk with Ivan, OK.
No, I had the idea that we already were starting to try to do that, but we didn't use N8M.
No, how to say, maybe how to say it's everything is already there, but it's not yet tested and whatsoever.
Yeah.
But that is from, hey, we have here now N8M servers, so you can start with even having N8M servers like in Putro where you running.
So it's a docker container, whatsoever.
Because like, honestly, it's a three week process.
First week?
It's exactly, but that is why.
Because then after we have the product, so to say, there's like this one week where people have to like learn how to use it and set it up for everybody.
No, the thing is, is you set up this project.
The first project is to set up one project, yeah.
And then is, how do you say, then it's up to me what they want you to do.
Are we going to set this up for all projects?
Or are you, how do you say, are we teaching?
How do you say you want to have a handover of this functionality?
Yeah, this should be just a quick execution.
And that doesn't mean that you can ask a good price.
Your price you're asking is high because you do this very fast.
Yeah, nobody's going to be able to do this for you in two weeks.
Exactly.
And that is what, as I said, even has more or less this already set up.
And the reason is why it needs to be done is because you say so fast, so much time and it shows you already how effective you are working.
Can I tell you my price estimate because I was thinking, you were telling me after this project you probably will be already on positive numbers.
Yes.
So I said, what is the actual amount of money we need to be on positive numbers?
Which is estimating, you know the last estimate that we almost made that is like 5k a month?
Yeah.
But it was a little less than that.
So I was thinking 45,000 for that.
I said, no, I don't think so.
You shouldn't be asking that one.
That's too much already.
That is too much.
What is the estimate that AI gave me?
AI gave me like 25,000.
So more between 15,000 and 25,000.
I think that is a fair price for it.
And now, because any team I was, who spent way more time on it.
But the thing is, you have, how do you say you can split it out in multiple stages.
The thing is, we are not here to melt you.
Yeah.
We are here to create time so your teams start creating time so the quality of the code goes up.
And how do you say, on one side, I think it's a one time thing.
That is a one time thing.
And that one you can set up here, you can help out and you can do that one.
Jacqueline can tune in or whatever and maybe someone with Jacqueline is adjusting that one.
That automated production workflow is the one that is actually going to be powered in.
How do you say you have your agent, your agent goes from blah blah blah to bite and throw.
You cannot help yourself.
You need to explain how it works.
Yeah.
No, but this tool is the one that takes over afterwards.
Yeah, but you are messing my audio because then I'm going to have mixed context.
Your audio will filter out those things, you know.
You are making...